>> Tucker: YESTERDAY CNN AIRED
A 16 MINUTE INTERVIEW WITH THE
COMMISSIONER OF THE NBA,
ADAM SILVER.
IN CABLE NEWS TIME, THAT’S
ETERNITY.
THEY NEEDED IT BECAUSE THERE’S A
LOT TO DISCUSS WITH SILVER.
NOT LEAST THE NBA’S LONG AND
CLOSE RELATIONSHIP WITH THE
COMMUNIST GOVERNMENT OF CHINA.
THE GOVERNMENT THAT IS SENDING
MINORITIES TO REEDUCATION CAMPS
AND FACILITATING SLAVE LABOR.
THOSE QUESTIONS NEVER GOT ASKED.
INSTEAD A CANVAS CASCADE OF SOFT
>> I ASSUME YOU WOULD CANCEL THE
NBA SEASON IF THAT WOULD BE THE
RIGHT THING TO DO IF IT INVOLVED
A PLAYER’S HEALTH AND SAFETY AND
OTHER PERSONNEL.
COACHES ET CETERA, YOU WOULD
JUST END THE SEASON, RIGHT?
WHAT WILL IT BE LIKE WATCHING
THESE GAMES ON TV, TO THE CAUSE
OF RACIAL JUSTICE IN OUR
COUNTRY?
HOW DO YOU SEE THE NBA’S ROLE IN
YOUR ROLE AS COMMISSION WHEN IT
COMES TO SUPPORTING THOSE
PLAYERS?
HOW DO YOU THINK WHOEVER WINS
THE NBA TITLE SHOULD BE
REMEMBERED?
>> Tucker: WOW.
HOW DO POWERFUL PEOPLE GET A
PASS FROM THE MEDIA?
SIMPLE.
BY BEING WOKE.
THE NBA PAINTED BLACK LIVES
MATTER ON ITS COURTS.
IT ALLOWS HIS PLAYERS TO NEIL
FOR THE NATIONAL ANTHEM, GIVING
THE FINGER TO THE COUNTRY THAT
MADE THIS SUPPORT POSSIBLE.
BURGESS OWENS NEVER KNEELED WHEN
HE WAS A PROFESSIONAL ATHLETE.
HE JOINS US TO RESPOND TO ALL OF
IT.
MR. OWENS, THANKS MUCH FOR
COMING ON.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF IT?
A BASKETBALL LEAGUE THAT’S TAKEN
AN EXPLICIT AND PARTISAN
POLITICAL POSITION?
>> WELL, THIS IS WHY I’M
RUNNING.
WE NEED TO DO IS MAKE SURE WE
UNDERSTAND WHO WERE DEALING
WITH.
TALKING ABOUT THE RADICAL LEFT.
THERE’S MORE THAN ANTIFA, IT’S
MORE THAN THE SOCIALISTS AND THE
DEMOCRATIC LEGISLATION.
IT’S CORPORATE COWARDS THAT HAD
TO HAVE THE MISERY OF OTHERS TO
GIVE THEM A WAY TO GET TO THEIR
BOTTOM LINE.
THEIR BOTTOM LINE IS PROFIT.
PROFIT IS POWER.
$1.5 BILLION CONTRACT, THE NBA.
THEY KNOW IF THEY’RE GOING TO
GET THAT, CAUSE HAVOC HERE AND
GET A PRESIDENT-ELECT AND MAKE
SURE THEY GET BACK TO CHINA.
IT’S ALL ABOUT NOVEMBER 2020
WHEN IT COMES DOWN TO DEMOCRATS.
THE RADICAL LEFT.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE
PEOPLE.
THEY DON’T CARE ABOUT THE BLACKS
IN THE BLACK COMMUNITY AND THEY
DON’T CARE ABOUT THE CHINESE
PEOPLE THAT ARE BEING OPPRESSED
IN CHINA WITH SLAVERY AND CHILD
LABOR IN THE WHOLE BIT.
THESE PEOPLE ARE REALLY ABOUT
THEMSELVES.
POWER AND PROFITABILITY.
NBA, NFL, NIKE.
>> Tucker: CORPORATE COWARDS
HIDING BEHIND THE SUFFERING OF
OTHERS.
I DON’T THINK I’VE EVER HEARD IT
BETTER THAN YOU JUST PUT IT.
QUICKLY IF YOU DON’T MIND, WHAT
DO YOU THINK THIS IS DOING TO
THE SPORT ITSELF?
>> IT’S DIVIDING US.
THE SPORT HAS ALWAYS BEEN USED
TO BRING US TOGETHER.
THAT’S THE POWER OF SPORTS AND
THE FLAG AND OUR NATIONAL ANTHEM
NATIONAL ANTHEM.
IT BRINGS US TOGETHER.
THESE FOLKS DO NOT CARE ABOUT
DIVIDING.
THEY DO NOT CARE ABOUT
DESTROYING THEIR SPORT AS LONG
AS THEY CAN GET THEIR
PROFITABILITY.
THEY ARE IN CHINA.
THEY ARE IN THEIR MONEY.
KEEP IN MIND THESE ARE THE WORST
OF AMERICA.
THEY CARE MORE ABOUT THEIR
PROFITABILITY, THEIR GROWTH IN
THEIR POWER THAN THEY CARE ABOUT
WE THE PEOPLE.
THEY ARE DESTROYING THE GAME.
THEY ARE DESTROYING CITIES
BECAUSE THEY WANT TO GET BIDEN
ELECTED IN 2020.
>> Tucker: I WISH I COULD